تنضم الينا صناعه المحتوى ضحى وزوجها محمد
نور ضحى ومحمد يسعد صباحكما شكرا على
تواجدكما معنا في صباح العربيه اهلا بكم
ولا نقول لك صباح الخير ضحى
طيب ضحى اعلنتي عن فرحان واحنا والله سعيد
بوجودك معانا انت ومحمد
والله الجدل كان في صالحي مكانش مضر لي
فالحمد لله يا ربي ما شفتش حتى مضره وفي
ناس يعني هي اغلبيه الضجه صارت فهمت الناس
الموضوع غلط ولسه الناس فاهمين الموضوع
غلط طب انت فهميهم يا ضحى موجوده معانا
على الهواء مباشره فهمينا
طيب الموضوع انه في ناس مفكرين انه انا كل
ساعه بدخل المبلغ هذاك وهي صارت معي صدفه
مره في الحياه يعني مره في حياتي دخلت
المبلغ هذاك فالناس هم مفكرين
مره في حياتي مليون دينار تونسي يعني 6500
دولار امريكي
في الساعه يعني اقل اقل اقل اقل خمسه خمسه
ولا اربعه في الساعه بساعه واحده مش
بالساعه يعني كانه كل ساعه انا بتدخل
المبلغ هذاك لانه في مرات بضل يعني بتعب
اسبوعي بفتح كل يوم وما بدخل ولا قرش يعني
انا ليش الناس بتشوف كانه الساعه هذيك
اللي انا دخلت فيها انا في مرات شهر كامل
بفتح وما بدخل وانا قرش يعني بشتغل بشتغل
شهر شهرين زي مثلا الناس اللي بتصور اوكي
ضحى خلينا كمان شوي نشوف محمد محمد يسعد
هالصباح اهلا بك معنا بصباح العربيه
محمد محمد اليوم في ناس في ناس عم بتشوف
انه اليوم مشاهير السوشيال ميديا بشكل عام
كانهم عم بيشجعوا العالم انه تتجه لدعايات
سوشيال ميديا وهذا الربح السريع والكسب
المادي السريع بدون فكره التركيز انه احنا
نكون مثال للعالم مثال للاجيال للشباب
للمراهقين لامور مثلا تربويه تعليميه اخرى
انتم كيف بتردوا على هذه الامور
ما في كسب ماده بالموضوع
هيك يعني خلاص حسمتها ما في كسب ماده يعني
انا لما
[موسيقى]
صار خلص جزء من معاشها كانه اللي بتاخده
باليوم وحتى بالشهر
موظف كامل كانه
لا لا
طيب اوكي خلينا نروح ضحى ضحى اليوم انا
كمان بدي اسالك يعني شغله انه عم بيقولوا
اليوم العالم انه ضحى عم تعطي مثال للناس
انه خصوصا انه ضحى مثلا لا تحمل شهاده
فانه انا كانه عم بعطي اسم مثال للناس مش
صح بالذات للمراهقين وعندك عدد كبير من
الملايين من المتابعين ملايين من
المتابعين انه انا الناس صارت خلاص بدها
تلحق مشهور السوشيال ميديا وهذا المشهور
مش ماشي مثلا بطريق التعليم وحمل الشهادات
والتدرج في الحياه
كيف بتردي عليهم
طيب
برد اول شيء انا اخلي الشهره على جنب انا
انسانه زيي زيكم انا انسانه انخلقت زيي
زيكم فلو انا بضر حياتي وبضر حالي على جال
ناس لا فانا صح ما كملتش دراستي لكن فيه
اشياء مثلا انه انا بذكيه خليت حالي عندي
مدخول خليت حالي انه انا شوف يعني لو كنت
بدير سمك اللي انا وصلت له هلا فالحمد لله
لكن بشجع وبرجع بشجع انه انا لو كنت دارسك
كنت احسن من هيك لو كنت دايسه كنت احسن من
هيك بكثير انا بشجع الناس انها تدرس لانه
في اكثر من موقف
في انه اكثر من موقف محرج صار لي في اكثر
موقف مش حلو بسبب الدراسه انك تحس حالك
انك مش دارس انك مش عارف انك مش مثقف فانا
بحب مثلا اللي بيتابعوني ودائما يعني
الناس اللي بتفرج فيا حتى في الستوريات
واللايفات انا بقول يعني بتمنى انه
يتابعوني يكونوا دارسين انا بتمناها يعني
يكونوا اكثر ما يشجعوني هما اصلا يصلحولي
في الكلمات يقولوا لي هذه الكلمه غلط هذه
صح لازم لازم الدراسه لازم حتى لو مشهوره
لازم
طيب ضحى انت عندك عشره ملايين متابعه على
تيك توك ومئات الالاف في المواقع التواصل
الاخرى شو اللي خلى الضحى تحقق كل هالنجاح
انا بقول الارقام ومحمد يصلح لي طيب ضحى
شو اللي خلاك تحققي كل هالنجاح باهتمام
والله باش نحكي كلمه اللي
نحب نحكي مليون متابع في ناس يقولوا هذه
ما عندها محتوى وهذه تافهه فهل هل يعقل 11
مليون شخص يعني تافهين فاكيد يتابعوا في
المدرسين المعلمين الاطباء الكل شيء في حب
من عند الله يجي هذا من عند ربي انسان
يحبك انسان يحب يتابعك فانتوما ما تجيوش
تحكموا علي انا نتوما هلا اجوا حطوا 11
مليون امامكم واسالوهم ليش بتابعوني ليش
بتحبوا ضحى والله والله يعني انا بطلع
عفويه فهلا يصل وقت الانسان يعني يوصل وقت
انه بده يفتح التلفون بس بده يضحك بس بده
يطفئي يشاهد انسان مش فايق مش متصنع مش
هيك بس اعلانات بس بده يضحك يغير جو يحس
كانه عاش مع شخصيه تشبه عاش مع شخص قريب
منه طيب محمد ونور يعني النجاح مهم لكن
الاستمراريه هي للا عندكم مخطط للمستقبل
ما بعد عالم السوشيال ميديا بس للترفيه
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
شكرا جزيلا
عندي برنامج بصور فيه
بتمنى لكل التوفيق للاسف انتهى وقتنا ضحى
ومحمد شكرا